these young boys from the Mexican state
of get NATO are learning combat
techniques they are the newest and
youngest recruits of a community run
militia their ages range from eight to
twelve years we can't even go outside
because the school we used to go to is
in another town
controlled by criminal gangs and if we
go there we could be kidnapped many of
the boys say violence in their
communities has grown out of hand
they're afraid to go back to school and
have traded their textbooks for rifles I
joined the Community Police Force to
help my people and my family they've
told me a lot about guns and about how
to defend last year there were nearly
sixteen hundred homicides registered in
ganado according to official sources
violence has become so common many
residents see no other choice than to
put firearms in the hands of anyone able
to wield them we're now doing this
because we like guns we are farmers we
work field to provide for our families
we are doing this because the government
has failed to keep our communities safe
recent images of armed children dressed
in fatigues and lined up like soldiers
have circulated on Mexican social media
they've also sparked new concerns from
children's rights groups the fact that
girls and boys participate in armed
groups has a series of implications when
it comes to their rights for starters
there's a risk to their lives also their
development they are often forced to
leave school there's also the impact on
their mental and emotional health over
the past decade violence in Mexico has
grown exponentially experts estimate
that in that time as many as 30,000
Mexican children and teenagers have been
involved in some form of gun violence
mexico's president has called the act of
arming children quote shameful vowing to
address the issue by creating more
opportunities for children with few
resources and limited access to
education
a debate in Mexico is now underway over
how to best care for the safety and
mental health of children in regions of
conflict it's clear however that what
these children really want is a normal
childhood Manuel de pollo al Jazeera
Mexico City